Batman Superman world's finest is one of
the best Comics out there right now and
there's no arguing that so this opens up
literally with Superman getting wrecked
I mean just getting it absolutely handed
to him by Ultra Morpho this is a guy
that can duplicate any element on Earth
and even elements that are not from
Earth as well as any superpower he comes
across quite literally this guy can turn
himself into a walking talking piece of
green Kryptonite and be as strong as
Superman now the question you have to
ask is where's Batman while Superman's
getting dominated this whole time
because fighting a giant piece of green
Kryptonite is not going too well what's
crazy about this is that when Batman
arrives on the scene he shows up in this
whole new suit of armor now here's what
makes this suit so deadly it's actually
composed of the metal men who are the
metal men okay we don't need to go into
detail about them because their history
is ridiculously lengthy but the long and
short of this is that the powers of the
metal man get give the bad suit super
strength it allows the suit to stretch
indefinitely it allows it to melt down
and then squeeze through any space and
then return to normal and it even allows
them to encase himself in lead to
protect him from any kind of radiation
but this guy jumps in and immediately
starts dominating ultramorpha because
the very nature of ultramorpho is sure
he can copy elements but is fighting
fire with fire at the very least this
guy does not know how to immediately
overcome the suit now that's the thing
about ultramorpho the longer he fights a
foe the more capable he becomes and
facing off against that foe part of that
is due to his ability to copy elements
but the other part of it is his ability
to copy Powers so that's what makes them
so dangerous here now what's really cool
about this fight is you've got
ultramorpho who's like turning himself
into a gaseous form so when Batman goes
to punch him it punches straight through
him so it's really awesome to see him
just kind of adapt on the Fly not only
that you basically have the metal man
who suddenly disperse off of Batman
basically abandoning this suit and then
in turn immediately go after Ultra
Morpho but one of them also bonds
themselves to Superman which allows him
to be encased in lead and then protect
himself from the influence of
ultramorpho it's cool it's really really
dope and I really hope this is a suit
that Batman keeps for the foreseeable
future the problem with this is that
ultramorpho turns himself to acid and
then blasts Robin with it which puts him
out of commission that he fires off a
super hot blast of energy which
basically takes out all the metal men
and even starts to overheat Mercury did
he turns himself into a toxic gas that
knocks out Batman and Superman and then
he flies off with him now the question
to ask here is where do the Metal Men
right like what happened to him so one
of the things to know about the metal
man is that they're programmed to
preserve human life at every possible
opportunity and so when Batman and
Superman were basically overtaken and
snatched away by ultramorpho the Metal
Man immediately grabbed Robin and
metamorph fell kind of the at least one
half of the template for ultramorpho
himself and they whisked them away to
safety that's what they're programmed to
do and so following this we pick up with
Batman and Superman waking up after
having been captured now both of them
have inhibitor collars with Superman it
makes sense because the inhibitor caller
shuts his powers down with Batman it
didn't initially make any sense the guy
has no powers I mean I guess you could
shut down his brain but then of what use
is he if he's just in a vegetative state
the other part of this inhibitor color
though is that it basically forces a
person to bend to Authority by literally
just electrocuting him but as they look
around what they start to realize here
is that you have all these individuals
who are experts in robotics and AI
villains and heroes alike who have been
snatched up and they're forced to
basically work on these robotic
components we don't know exactly what
it's all going towards but their initial
thought here is that Dr Anthony Ivo is
the one behind all of this why because
Anthony Ivo is the one who created
Amazon and even and when they first
faced off against ultramorpho and
whenever he talked the voice they heard
was Anthony ivo's voice so by all
standards the measurement Ivo was the
one pulling the strings but that turns
out to not be the case because they spot
Dr Ivo as one of the people being held
prisoner here which means somebody else
out there is controlling ultramorpho and
so even when they start asking questions
one of the things they're told by Ivo is
no right do not ask questions he doesn't
like it when you talk you get
electrocuted when that happens which is
exactly what happens to Batman and
Superman their next thought here is that
Amazo had basically broken free of
control from Anthony Ivo and he's the
one running the show but then we find
out amazos here as well again Amazo is
the one that has the ability to copy
Powers metamorpho copies elements
ultramorpho is the both of them combined
into one robot and so as they keep
asking questions despite the fact that
they know they're not supposed to this
kind of disembodied voice comes out of
nowhere only for us to find that is
basically called new meso it's a new
Amazo so the question that has to be
asked here is if you have ultramorpho
that can copy powers and elements and
was able to overpower Batman and
Superman and that thing's answering to a
meso 2.0 or new meso what possible
powers can this dude have that that
robot Ultra Morpho would answer to him
is it just simple programming or is this
dude on a whole nother level we don't
know but we'll find out in the next
video with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
all for watching and I will catch you
all later
peace